hi today we have somewhat of a long
episode because I had a couple of time
lapses and just the first two would be a
bit too short because that would be
seven minutes but now there's another
one and that make the total video almost
60 minutes I think which is a little bit
too long and a little bit on the long
side but it's not terrible so I guess I
can just do that but I am almost running
out of time because I have to go into
Rotterdam in a bit so I only have this
one opportunity this one moment to seize
everything I've ever won it so I do it I
have to do it right now so basically
what we're going to do today is work on
the Main Street just a bit more I don't
exactly know how many episodes I'll
still be doing this I mean let me check
my videos there's one time I was over
here there's another one that's three
four five oh my there are still six time
lapses of the Main Street but a couple
ones of those are just about an hour
long I think the average is actually an
hour so that'll translate into roughly
three episodes and then the Main Street
should be done at least the Main Street
should be done in terms of buildings I
still need to add a square to it because
also I do the Main Street I want to add
the square that's after the Main Street
so the Disneyland is square which is
going to have either that fountain or a
chair swing or whatever I feel like but
I also want to have some small entrance
flat and square because you know I do
want to get something similar to
Disneyland plus I've already reserved
some land space in front of these
entrance so I might as well actually use
that one thing that I'm actually not too
certain about is whether this sandbox is
actually going to be large enough for
this park so either I'll have to really
watch out with how big I'm going to make
this bike or I have to move everything
into a custom scenario which wouldn't be
a problem either and I might actually do
that anyway because then you can control
the weather and stuff like that but I'm
really not used to using scenarios and
in general the sandbox should be big
enough for a park so I'll try the
sandbox but if it really doesn't work I
have to migrate it to a to a custom
scenario but I'll have to do that in a
pretty early stage because at this stage
everything in the park so far is
actually kind of fake it's nothing at
all there are no paths you had no
attractions and it's all just custom
scenery that all this stuff is based on
I should probably talk a bit about the
buildings but
honestly these aren't really two
interests interesting these were just a
couple of filler buildings that I wanted
to get in there because I wanted to get
that square feeling like you're in the
middle of a city or a Main Street rather
in this case but I couldn't really fill
up the entire square with amazing
beautiful buildings even if I could I
probably would have gotten bored or just
don't care so yeah I'm sorry but there's
gonna be some fellow down time in the
square as well but this building just I
still kind of feel like it fits in there
it's a bit of a Dutch building and I
think it's the only real Dutch slash
Flemish I always feel like it's more
Flemish because it has those gray stones
which you kind of see more often in and
work them in some Dutch cities but it's
the same similar Conte style anyway so
it doesn't really matter that much and
yes I did just say that if I'm going to
do a theme which is going to be based
around this area I'm just going to call
Holland and Flanders the same area so
I'm sorry to all the people who are
offended but in a cultural way when
those buildings were built they were
pretty much the same country so yeah
that's something that I figured I would
actually think about and taking into
consideration when I was building the
buildings this building is a bit of a
mirror image of the building on the
other side except it has very different
details I have you you can actually see
me looking at the building on the other
side every now and then in the time
perhaps to see what kind of things I did
because it does have many similarities
especially in the pillars and the types
of walls that are used though the
details are always different because
that is something to always take into
account that's even though some
buildings in the Main Street may end up
similar because of similar custom
scenery use or just because you're
running out of things that go well with
the themes but don't really have too
much of a contrast with the rest of the
building in the main street you should
always realize that you don't want to
have too many of the same details on
this on all the buildings because that
would mean that the buildings just
looked too similar on the Main Street as
a whole so then it's also something that
I wanted to keep remembering when I was
building these buildings and now a
couple of objects with which I kind of
failed as you can see there are many
buildings which have that standard Main
Street roof be it with either the dark
texture or the light texture and one of
the reasons for that is I tried a couple
of other roofs to track the roofs from
Station Jim spooky set like what I
always call it spooky set but
as in the name like it goes cabin Matt's
name and rct3 Adam's birthday Manor
which is also made by station Jim jr.
but those groups just didn't really have
the same Main Street ring to it that the
Main Street groups had so I had to kind
of overuse those rubes and the balconies
balconies are still built for problem
because every single balcony so far that
I've placed is from Main streets at one
because that's the only good balcony
that I think really fits with the theme
and to be very honest there aren't
really too many balconies in Monaco
sticking through you have that type of
fence and decoration on it so that's
building issue I might actually want to
make my own but that's only if I
actually feel like it I'm probably going
to be too lazy to do not have to do that
anyway so but not not might calm at some
point in time actually I think the next
episode to be the first episode in which
I'll do some custom scenery I don't
think I've really talked about this too
much but one of the things that I'm
planning for this park is to every time
I run into some kind of object that I
need but doesn't exist in the game or it
doesn't have the right texture or it
just doesn't nearly have the right shape
or size or whatever I'm just going to
make my own custom scenery this is
something that I've done before but it's
something that I was a bit hesitant to
do in my let's play because it is
something that you can't really film and
it's still part of the park creating
process but I'm not going to film it but
I will actually try to make as much
custom scenery and not let me be too
limited by the limited amount of custom
scenery that's available so far and at
the end when I do have a set hopefully
that's just made for this park that
actually has some usable pieces in it
I'll release that as well though it
might become a very very jumbled mess
and this is something that some people
may have actually seen when they've
downloaded my style theme for me I
haven't really said sorry about this
because I should definitely excuse
myself
because my style theme for this is the
bit of a mess when it comes to some
things because usually what I do when I
need to cut some scenery piece and it
doesn't exist yet in the game I just
whip it up in the Google Sketchup and
import it but I never never ever
actually do the effort to get the right
icons and write names so there's a
couple of items really weird
names and random icons scattered
throughout my style theme and those also
in my Wars and object photos and that
might also be a bit a bit weird and to
be very honest I still need to get to
doing the icons with various sets I
still keep promising everybody that I'll
release some of my custom scenery sets
but there's still all just in beta and
still just downloadable from my style
theme follow so one thing that I am
planning on doing is getting the best
pieces from all my random custom scenery
sets that mostly the pieces that I've
been using the most and just put them in
one set and call that like silver and
until the pieces that I've been using
for all these times can actually be used
by other people as well that seems like
a nice thing regardless I should do that
because I always complain about other
people not releasing those sets which is
very annoying I am very much against
people not releasing things that you
know could be public that is unless it
is really made specifically for your
projects and I just [ __ ] dropped my
phone but yeah some people just I don't
know there's just these very underused
sets that aren't officially release and
just kind of go around hand to hand the
hand from hand and it's it's it I don't
know it's not something that I'm a huge
fan of but yeah I feel like I am NOT
very entitled to completely about that
when I only have some betas of my sets
in my style theme folders and I just
kind of keep them you know I'm not very
officially out there yet I do which is
mostly due to the fact actually that I'm
very hesitant to add icons to it because
that's pretty much one of the only
things that I still need to do and many
of my sets it is add icons to it but
that's just the most boring thing ever
but that's also another thing that I'd
really can't complain about because I
always complain about people who don't
put icons and there cuz some scene
resets and they have hundreds of pieces
but no no none of the pieces actually
have a pictures so it's really hard to
find what you're looking for
and I always like to complain about that
but it's probably not entitled to do
that either because I rarely have any
icons of my sets either so I really have
to get to that in any case this building
this building is that that mirror image
building that I've talked about in the
earlier episode that would kind of
resemble the building on the other side
but not like
players you can tell there's a different
roof some different colors some
different windows and different details
but as a whole the building is quite
similar mainly due to the fact that it
has the same shape and size and naught
and it also should function as a
restaurant don't have any interiors yet
and I've actually spoken to people about
interior stuff because that's something
that this Main Street misses it's got a
couple of buildings that are assigned as
shops and a couple of buildings that are
restaurants that would be these two
buildings and in the future some
building will be assigned two toilets
but this is this thing that none of the
buildings are actually functional when
you go into them I don't know if I'm
actually going to do that or not because
in general I'm just much more interested
in exteriors and I really suck and
interiors - so I don't know if I'll
really be getting to that but I do want
to make this main street at least look
as lively as I can so after I finished
the main street some time after I
finished the main street that is I do
want to add some very small details and
by that I don't mean really building
details but just details that make it
look more lively like the real Main
Street has some flags and lights hanging
around and you have some signs in the
building stuff like that it was really
something that it doesn't make the
buildings look more good but it does
make the Main Street as a whole look a
lot more like it's actually in a theme
park and actually like a nice nice place
to be
and it helps the atmosphere I guess but
yeah that's also something for another
time and perhaps even a time after I
finished the main street and it squares
and stuff because I do notice that the
more I'm working on this the more some
people are like you know you should
actually get to some rollercoasters as
well and the more I also start thinking
about roller coasters because there's
yeah there are a couple of ideas that I
really want to try out and I've read it
in the comments and a bnm dive machine
and a B&M inverts are definitely two
things that I were to think about neck
book they've both got their pros and
cons obviously and a dive machine is
really cool because I really like rippin
and I like the way that it's themed
around the pathways I think what you can
do with dive machines in the paths
around them is really nice but also the
efteling has done some really amazing
things with Baron 1898 the thing you can
do
and as the way you pronounce it in Dutch
language but yeah and I don't really
know if I want to do that because
there's also this thing about being I'm
inverts that I really really like
because it's so good when it comes to
theming you can do loads of tea new
scenery interaction and part the
interaction with vnm inverts and the
layouts you can also do a lot with
layouts you can keep them small somewhat
smaller than some of the other BMS they
don't stand out as much but they they
are much more subtle when it comes to
the scenery in the way they look so
that's also a nice thing but I have been
kind of overusing bnm inputs because I
wanted my favorite Kota types because of
the aforementioned scenery reasons so
yeah that's also one reason to consider
a dive machine over an invert I will
probably do either one because I'm not
sure whether I want to have to be MEMS
but it might just happen if I really
feel like an into bananas then it might
just happen I mean after all Busch
Gardens by that I mean Williamsburg
actually has a bnm inverts and a dive
machine as well and I do like the
theming around both rides
though I would like to make it a bit
more a bit more heavily themed if I ever
do an invert it is not going to be an
input like alpengeist but more something
like black mimosa or something like
nemesis which are both amazing coasters
because if I do coasters I do want to
have some intense rides in here but I
want every single ride even the roller
coasters to at least be very confined
within the space of theming because I
always feel like a theme park is a bit
of a net immersion experience almost a
bit like a TV show is an immersion where
as you're in this different kind of land
you're in this fantasy land where
everything is great and the rest of the
world are shitty and you know you don't
want to get taken away from that and
with some parks like Europa Park it is
all beautiful you're you're in all types
of countries in the world and then you
go on Silver Star and you're in a
parking lot just that's the problem that
I have with enormous coast is like bnm
inverts and I'm like big bnm invert
beam I'm Hyper's and intimate mako stuff
like that that it is so big that you
can't properly theme the entire thing
and I guess it takes away from the
immersion a bit that is not to say that
that bad
say but they would be banned in a pike
that stripes was something that Disney
tries to strive for or the efteling or
whatever Park has heavy theming
I guess Fantasyland is also a very good
example because it does take away from
the immersion and that immersion is
something that I do want to keep if
you're in this park you're going to be
in this park and you're not going to see
anything that takes you away from the
pike and if you have a bnm hypo that
you're 10,000 kilometres up in the air
and you can see New York in the distance
and it's just something that I don't
know if I really want to have that in
this pike but yeah that's that's just
one reason why I'm trying not to
consider those things when it comes to
other rollercoasters I've gotten some
pretty good suggestions as well I
definitely want to try a log flume and
if I do I want to try something like
choppers I don't know if that's the
right way of pronouncing it but anyway
there's this really awesome log flume in
Fantasia Island which has amazing
theming it is very heavily themed it's
got three drops and it also goes
backwards and it has an airtime Hill an
airtime Hill log flume is something I
want to try or it could also do some log
flume that actually has a curved track
like a Yokohama Cosmo world but yeah
I'll look at that some point basically
the rides are going to be Disney ish but
on steroids I guess it's a nice way to
put it
but I also want to have some cool kiddy
rides because I like kiddie rides and
one thing though if I do something else
then bnm coasters or a mine train
because I definitely want to have my
train yes I definitely like big grizzly
Mountain runaway trains mine train that
is in Hong Kong Disneyland because that
is my favorite coaster ever and I've
always wanted to do some mind training
like that but if I do a coaster that's
not on my train or be Namco Street I am
kind of hesitant to built them already
because as you may or may not know the
PEP team who are known for the Europa
pack one and two are working on new
cities and this new these new cities
would be a extension to the existing
in-game tracks so they've got a CT for
the intimate track I don't know which
track that was but anyway they added new
elements like diagonal looping and very
smooth curves and stuff like that and
they also added new elements to the
in-game track 11 track which would be
the Schwartz called
stretch track but I think it is for me
Rhianna premiere but I kind of worried
for that because I'd feel kind of bad if
I already added coasters of those tracks
and then suddenly the CTS came out and I
could have been I could have been making
much better rollercoasters so if I do do
do rollercoasters I want to do the be in
a mess in the mine train first so the
other stuff is going to have to wait
anyway that's it for this episode thank
you for watching and I'll see you on the
next one